We recently introduced a
vector quantity called torque--
a sort of rotational
analog to force.
And we saw that an applied
torque changes the angular
motion of a rotating
body in just the same way
that an applied force
changes the linear motion
of a translating body.
This week, we're
going to introduce
the concept of angular
momentum, which
relates to torque and rotational
motion in the same way
that ordinary momentum
relates to force
and translation of motion.
Like torque, angular
momentum is defined
in terms of a cross product
or a vector product.
Specifically, the angular
momentum vector L for a point
mass is equal to the
cross product R cross P ,
where R is the position
vector measured from a chosen
reference point and P is the
ordinary momentum vector.
We will also encounter a
third conservation principle,
this time for angular momentum.
An applied torque causes the
angle the moment of to change.
However, if there are no
external torques on a system,
then the angular
momentum of the system
is conserved or
remains constant.
This is a powerful tool
for solving many problems.
One subtlety is that
angular momentum like torque
is defined relative
to a specified point.
So for a given system,
the angular momentum
with respect to one
point might be conserved,
while the angular momentum with
respect to a different point
might be changing.
Often in analyzing
the system, we
must be careful about our
choice of reference point
for torques and angular
momentum in order
to take full advantage of
the conservation principle.
Angular momentum
is a particularly
subtle and non-intuitive
concept in comparison
to momentum and energy.
And the resulting motion
is often surprising.
It is worthy of
particularly careful study.